if it's a true artist it ain't about the
money it's not about the brand it's not
about any of that it's about did I move
to people I'm going to read for Oliver
Stone and when I read for Oliver Stone
he says well you're just no good I was
like what you're no good you're no good
he told you that it tells me this to my
face you're no good because once you
rest and once you say it's over I've
gotten to the mountaintop then your
talent starts to dwindle to need
motivation watch top 10 of leaving
nation what's up at 7:00 my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have Michael Jordan level talent
adds something and I want you to find it
embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's get your motivation
to attend and get you believing in you
grab a snack and join today's lessons
from a man who went from being adopted
by his mother's adoptive parents and
growing up in a racially segregated
community to becoming a Grammy
award-winning musician an oscar-winning
actor he's Jamie Foxx and here's my take
on his top ten roses success
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one take responsibility
we did this movie where I play this guy
where he said hey you know what
[Applause]
you don't see them
[Applause]
so I I did I played Ray Charles and I
eat it but I'm gonna make it do what you
do baby and when we play Ray Charles we
didn't know what we were doing in that
movie that was an independent movie it
went on to get nominated for an Oscar he
was a problem when we got nominated for
an Oscar I thought there's no way we win
so I use that as an excuse to throw
parties let's turn up right yeah then I
get a call for somebody hi Jimmy Fox
this is Oprah I'm like who yeah what
what who that's Oprah she says you're
blowing it I said what you mean no she
says you got an opportunity to do
something great walk into the history
books and you're blowing it and I need
to help you with it and I said well I'm
sorry what I need to do so she took me
to Quincy Jones's house Oh
and Quincy came out hey man you're doing
great job with ray-ban and you man you
really did that man I remember Michael
954 million records with Thriller baby I
remembered that man but you have to walk
a certain way Jamie because you don't
want to blow it man everybody's counting
on you man and I said thank you and he
takes me into his house and there was
people from the 60s and the 70s that
have been actors and actresses all
dressed up to say walk the right way do
the right thing because we count on you
because we never would have thought this
would happen
and so Oprah comes up she says I wanted
to do this for you because you need to
understand the significance of things
and a lot of times people don't
understand that she says now are you
ready to meet the person that you're
here for I said yeah and standing over
in the corner was Sidney Poitier
Wow going to City porn in Sydney 48 I
mean you know I saw you one time just
dude do anybody nice he said I I saw you
at the party do you remember that and I
was I just started crying I was like
yeah yeah and he says your performance
made me grow 2 inches and I was like I
appreciate it he says Oprah and I would
like to give you one thing I said what's
that responsibility
so you're responsible for your art you
responsible for this moment and so
that's the Oprah Winfrey who took that
moment to where I could have blew it in
the club and we ended up walking through
and making history and everybody rule
number two move the people what makes me
happy man is seeing the result of you
creating something in your living room
or in your bathroom I idea a joke a song
and then seeing the whole world repeated
like when I was on a living color
everybody was in it was competing back
that was 92 93 we were competing on that
show Jim Carrey the Wayans brothers we
was like who could come up with the line
or the joke that everybody will say the
next day on Monday like I came up with a
playing his character that I'll rock
your world and then next thing you know
our rocker world became t-shirts and all
just took actually come up with that to
barge in on Kanye's studio session when
I wasn't on their record and they say
just come up with something and then
sing that line and then be in my line in
Italy and sing it and watch people who
don't necessarily know how to speak all
English but they know the line that's
the most incredible thing if it's a true
artist it ain't about the money it's not
about the brand it's not about any of
that it's about that I move the people
in it in it and it doesn't have to be it
doesn't have to be the whole world it
could be like a niche like 30 people out
of all these thousands knew that thing
that you did and so that's what makes me
happy man because it's like it's it's
it's the ultimate
it's it's the ultimate gratification you
know because it's like now and now in
social media it can happen that quick
like you know back in the day you know
you have to read about it a few and now
people could tell you either you suck
that sucked
don't do that don't do that again or
back or we dig it so that that's what
it's the best what makes me happy yeah
it seems like you know no matter what
you're doing we're all like a force and
that force needs in effect if you're the
wind do you need the talker flow over a
trees demand illness you know it's so
eloquent that was so eloquent rule
number three persevere any given Sunday
was an incredible moment because I was
doing the Jamie Foxx show and they were
getting ready to cancel us before a
hundred episodes
it sounds like man please and then any
given Sunday came up and I went in to
read for Oliver Stone everybody know
Oliver Stone I'm sure I'm going to read
for Oliver Stone and when I read for
Oliver Stone he says well you're just no
good I was like what you're no good
you're no good he told you that
he tells me this to my face you're no
good and I was like yeah it's no good
and then because I read for I don't know
what I read for one of the running backs
um it was a just a part I was reading
for yeah you know and then the the the
casting lady said why don't you come
back and read for something else yeah he
could and as I walked away Oliver Stone
says this so I could hear it as he's
writing some down jamie foxx slave to
television you know I think he called me
someone took on a name up my name and
he's like j-just really no no I hate
right and then they had me come back and
read for another part before the part of
the agent and I read and after I did
that he says well you're just no good at
that either
and I'm like so how did you but hot it
how do you hear that and and stick with
it
it wrecks you but what it does is it
lets you know what you got because I
left and I said doc that died and I
called my agent I was on in living color
and I was the greatest on there and I
was he doesn't know who I am I'm Jamie
Foxx and they're like yeah Jay but in
living color was on a cool Network it
wasn't a bit network and Warner Brothers
is okay now so not a lot of people know
yeah and so next thing you know I
actually get a callback you got the part
of the agent so when I get when I go
back I said I'm gonna let him know how I
feel so when I walked when I walked in
there I said I'm gonna tell you
something man so what is it and he was
all relaxed I said man you disrespected
me man and understand what I'm doing man
I mean I'm trying to get this he says
relax
he says you're good but you are a slave
to television because you're allowed
because on TV we have to hey man how you
feel today
alright and so on so he says movies are
like this and if you act like that on
the movie on that big screen it's gonna
be too much overwhelming I said okay he
said now so I got a problem I said
what's the problem
he says the person who I wanted to play
the quarterback is not working out I
need to find somebody who could play the
quarterback I said I happened I played
quarterback in high school I pass over
thousand yards I didn't tell them about
the interception
and I said listen I don't want to step
on nobody's toes I said but I can get
that so during that time I started
learning my lines and every time I came
in he was like you're terrible
you stink you got you gotta be the
person you're trying to act like you're
being the person you have to get it and
that's what I learned about a true
director this was a good training for me
so what I did was I got all my homies
together remember that 97 coupe the
Mercedes absolutely I rented a got
somebody's coupe to drive around so I
had somebody film me in the coupe and I
get out and all my football gear like
we're a training camp and so I'm
throwing you know like literally I'm
throwing passes outs and whatever and I
came up with this little champ my name
is Willie Willie PA man I keep them
ladies cream and all my fans got a
scream and think you can't defeat me
you're dreaming so we did a little I had
a little music set up I did a little
beat and put that together and made this
tape gave it to Oliver Stone got hired
that's how so so actually it's it's a
lesson in perseverance it's a lesson in
a ham body you don't hear what you need
to hear you make it what you want to
exactly and and and you know it because
you had a coach oh you Mike you gotta
you have to give more than the next guy
rule number four be driven I had to
learn Drive that's why I have my
managers to teach me drive or to you
know push me because you can relax you
guys how I could do that or I could do
that but are you gonna be that person I
know this person this person who calls
me young man did you see what Denzel did
in that movie man and that was and
you're like he said I could have and
maybe he could have but he doesn't have
to drive the Denzel and so therefore if
you don't have Drive then you never you
you quit cultivating your talent because
once you rest and once you say it's over
I've gotten to the mountaintop then your
talent starts to dwindle too that's why
I just a minute the war season's over I
was at Wet Willie's in Miami doing jokes
for people just on the street knows like
what just to see what would work you
know jokes either about the Oscars or
jokes about whatever and then you go to
Atlanta and work on your jokes there so
that hustle what I call hustle is very
important because
at some point you're gonna be able to
pull the hustle back just a little bit
and then you pick your spots the time
right now is the hustle to set things up
so that in the future you're able to cut
back just a little bit and just pick
your spot rule number five turn your
light on that kind of day you look at
Richard Pryor and they okay he did an
arc high whatever it was and we were
like oh maybe we have to follow that
right but you know that that where's
your tread down there wears you down so
I just had I wake up and do it I wake up
and do like this mental check system I'm
in this situation I'm in a situation
where I'm able to create and that's my
job and then I look at what I could have
been doing and so I turn my light on I
said I'm gonna turn my light on no
matter what no matter if I'm tired or if
I'm red whatever it is I'll turn my
light on and that saves you because a
lot of people turn the lights off if you
especially if you look at comedians
comedians when they reach a certain
plateau and they've done so great they
start trying to look sexy and you know
check out their money yeah they start
working out too much you know it's weird
and then they turn that light off and
they're afraid to to be goofy again when
I wake up I said I'm not gonna be afraid
to be goofy I'm not gonna afraid to be
I'm not afraid to challenge myself and
it's just a mental thing that you do
when you wake up and then once you do
that I want you to learn how to tap into
it you don't need any of the other stuff
rule number six play the right notes I'm
playing with Ray Charles then we're
playing you know just sort of bluesy
stuff and anyone into the Stallone he's
a monk yeah and that's really intricate
in that you're playing in it and then
we're doing the Lotus one and then I hit
a wrong nobody said hey you know what
why the hell would you do that I said
what he said why get the wrong note
that's our knowledge playing I he says
listen take time to hit the right notes
that's basically what life is finding
the right notes to play and so I always
sort of use that is you know I don't
know what you call the word but you know
my inspiration how do I now play the
right notes play the right notes for me
as a person because I want to fulfill my
thing but play the right notes for my
family and I think the the trickiest
part because he says life is underneath
life is underneath your finger and at
life is under here
I think the fingers and all the notes
are there you just have to make sure
that you find the right now so yeah rule
number seven get confidence you know I
want young people to get on them I want
them to get confidence and I want to
think like I think I think that there's
nothing in the world that I could
absolutely be when we were in Atlanta we
did the Laffer pollution we do it every
every year this was our best year
because we're coming off of that Oscar
and we're coming right into this
african-american community where these
kids are looking and we had the teens of
comedy these young guys with confidence
and swagger and bravado I said to all
you kids in here I want you to be able
to think that every option is open my
grandmother taught me every option is
open because when you own the other side
of those tracks or when you feel like
you're not you know not you're not
pretty or that you're not this or
whatever that that mentality is going on
in the neighborhood you know you can
stay stagnant in that you can just stay
like well I could never but you really
can and so the most important thing is
confidence give them confidence and
little bit of ministry that's easy to
say it's easy to say but here's an how
do you get it how do you get it is that
you keep letting them know you keep
going back every year and then you try
to everybody's not gonna be able to do
what I do you know saying everybody's
not gonna be able to be a star act like
we went back to the letter said I said
how you kids doing my young boxes my
young lawyers my young whatever it is
and just keep giving them confidence
rule number eight study the greats
growing up I always watched the Tom
Jones Show or or this is way young this
is way way before you guys time to like
watch it Johnny Carson Sammy Davis jr.
some of these old heads who song dance
you know did it all like Dean Martin and
Frank Sinatra and those guys so after
you have the natural blessing another
talent it's seeing how oh that's how I
put it together so if you're watching if
you're watching Richard Pryor okay
that's how I put my set together or if
you're watching Eddie Murphy oh that's
how you make it a superstar look cuz
Eddie was interested he was able to do
all of that
for some of the young guys something
young Millennials that day I was talking
my Murphy the other day was like I think
that the do to be in the forest with you
yeah that's what they know I said but I
knew him when he would when he had on
the blue leather and he was talking
trash you know and he was he made being
a comedian like fly like you nobody did
that you know so when you watch Kevin
Hart that's an exact sort of the DNA of
what Eddie was rule number nine change
your environment
there was this one instance that changed
the way I viewed life when my friend was
17 I was 16 and I get a chance to go
play for this big house you know in
Texas out out in the country and it's
Christmas time mm-hmm when I get there
not gonna do any guy open the door
what's going on here I said what sir I'm
here to play for your uh your Christmas
party
then why are two of you here I said what
you know he drove I didn't have a you
know license so you know I said sir a
problem he says yeah I can't have two
[ __ ] in my house at the same time now
mind you I've heard that word said to me
so much it didn't bother like well okay
well listen Ken can he just wait in the
drive well he said he can't wait on this
street and I look it starts at 6:30 make
up your mind so I told my boy to come
back at 8:15 8:30 which was late for us
at that time and he says hey where's
your tuxedo I said they didn't tell us
to get one he says well come on in this
room and he took me on a walk-in closet
now look why doesn't that got all his
clothes in his bedroom yeah but he gave
me I don't know if y'all remember the
Brooks Brothers suit yet patches I'm
playing as I'm playing Oh as I'm playing
right they're doing black jokes you know
you can buy them doing J they're doing
dope nickel oh man we're just funny
come on now we just fun didn't and so
I'm just playing but the reason that I
was calm is because my grandmother
taught me something called furniture
since she worked you know as a mage he
says you know then the word is furniture
whenever they're doing whatever that
they're doing you're just furniture you
don't respond and then the lady of the
house is apologize for what's going on
here could you sing us something as I
said cool chestnuts roasting no no no
I'm fine okay and the guy says hey man I
like that right then afterwards he gave
me 100
at night night hundred call me [ __ ]
everyday I got me a hundred dollars hey
I'm cool but I remember about to give
him the jacket back he said I can't wear
that anymore and then he made me wait
outside up the street and that night
when Chris who by the way he was my best
friend who actually lives at my house
now when he picked me up I said listen I
gotta get out of here I gotta get out of
this place because I'm too smart for
what's going on right now and either I'm
gonna hurt somebody or someone's gonna
hurt me because eventually I can't take
too much more of of that in the nest
when I decided to go to college in San
Diego and rule number 10 the last one
before a very special bonus clip is tell
great stories well how do you go from
classical pianist you know singing in
church college to comedy I was always a
clown
I was always a clown I was always
clowning in school I remember in the
third grade miss Reeves would give me a
time at the end of class to do jokes and
stuff like that
because I was always getting in trouble
but I was smart - sorry
finished my work of he's in there with
my young making noise I'm so I'm gonna
give you time at the end of class and I
would watch The Tonight Show so I would
watch Johnny Carson and you know and yet
did you know that earlier today it was
so hot so I would watch all the Johnny
Carson and watch you know David Brenner
and all the different acts that will
come on there and I was just used those
jokes for my jokes well hold on though
some of those jokes weren't meant for
the school I know but but here's the
thing here's the thing it was only one
TV in my house and it was in the room I
slept so my grandmother had to watch
Johnny Carson so I had to watch Johnny
Carson - so that's how I got you know
Lola Falana and all the different
remember Lola Falana with y'all give it
up a Lola Falana and it was just amazing
so I would take those jokes and you
don't was crazy about Johnny Carson
sitting on the couch we saw if you sat
on the couch you made it yeah yeah and
that was a singer you know I don't know
if you remember his name was Joe
Williams
dark tall image oh and before
I would be sure that someday you would
find and if I would be no right
thank you but here's the thing Joe never
got a chance to sit on the couch right
my grandma said oh I wish one day I wish
the Jesus would just let Joe I was Jesus
but let Joe sit on that couch with
Johnny Carson he sang so well for so
many years and so we see Noah and every
every time Joe will come on we sit like
okay maybe just maybe Joe will [ __ ] on
the couch today right so Joe sing any
boy would once again I've sung a song I
haven't sat on the couch maybe like
right and I guess someone had cancelled
so Johnny Carson says come on sit on the
couch Joe we was like but Joe went to
run over there cuz he was so excited and
the microphone cord was tied around his
foot and Joe fell
[Laughter]
and Joe was like trying to get to the
couch
and Joe was trying to get to the counts
and then they went to commercial
[Applause]
who like damn Joe they wrote me that
hurt my grandmother's landscape believe
Joe was so close with the commercial on
Joe's ass
I've got a really special bonus clip
from Jamie Foxx and how to have energy
but before that I want to know what did
you learn from this video what was the
single most important lesson that you're
going to apply somehow to your life or
your business let me know leaving the
comments below and when you write it
down you're much more likely to actually
take action on that thing that you need
to improve so leave it in the comments
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love see you soon and
enjoy the bonus clip
just a few hundred feet down at the
Comedy Store there was a guy named Eric
Bishop which is my actually that's my
real name
Eric Marlon Bishop who's at the Comedy
Store who was just got my jokes I would
literally I stayed at this place called
the Hastings Hotel on Hollywood
Boulevard it's torn down now but it was
just like derelict sand crazy view and I
bought my own stuff and I would buy
those three minutes burritos from
7-eleven I put I bought me a little
microwave I put it in and work on my
three minutes set while it's cooking the
reward at the end of burrito yeah finish
my burrito and then go down to the
comedy show I'm Eric Bishop I get on and
I get a standing ovation everybody's
going crazy then I came back I couldn't
get back on because the comedian's ran
the list and they saw that I got a
standing ovation and nice so they would
never put me back on so I was like damn
so I started going to other comedy clubs
I ended up at the Santa Monica improv
and they were they were having the
evening at the improv back in the day
and at that time like hundreds of guys
would show up for the potluck for the
for the open mic night and it would be
three girls that was show up the three
girls will always get on so I said you
know what dammit i'ma write on this
paper is Stacy green Tracy Brown Jamie
Foxx they end up picking the name Jamie
Foxx thinking that I was a girl Jamie
Foxx is she here you're gonna go first I
thought but that's that that's me oh
okay and I go up in the middle of the
show they called me fresh meat because
they were actually taping real comedians
and they said put the fresh meat up
you're thinking I'm gonna get booed and
I ended up getting a standing ovation
that's when Jamie Foxx was born about 27
years ago Jamie Foxx is born and that's
when everything started and it was crazy
after that night people thought I was
arrogant because it was it here that's
that guy right there I just got standing
ovations Jamie and I'm like Jamie I'm
not used to the name that's it now I'm
just trying to get used to the tonight
and then what I did after that once I
got that Jamie Foxx and I added the
because paying homage to Redd Foxx Jack
Letterman's jacket or hand at that time
like in 1990 so everybody had a letter
in this jacket so I went and saved up
got me a letter in this jacket and I
started working on the name so on the
back of my jacket said sly as a dot dot
dot nice so you know I was nice you talk
but but when you talk about the energy
of being Jamie Foxx that is it and
that's why like it was on the internet
or Twitter people didn't know that my
name was Eric bishop it was like crazy
people going crazy I said yeah but not
to talk in third and fourth person but
Eric Bishop centers Jamie Foxx like Eric
bishop is Terrell Texas never left that
never forget that I'm from Eric turns
the lights on exactly he turns on the
light he's from Terrell Texas never
changed my family lives with me from
Texas my sister the 27 years that I've
been Jamie Foxx has never called me
Jamie Foxx
she calls me Erin yeah so why you will
call me Jeong I call you that I don't
know what that is Jamie Potts what is
that you got to stay real and it's
interesting Eric bishop is like Clark
Kent Jamie Foxx is like the Superman
yeah and it does take energy to to be
Jamie right that makes it yeah if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that songs you Apple
so it would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details
[Music]